-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
James Austin Johnson.
I was listening to a podcast
that you were on.
And you were doing
your Trump impression,
talking about the sort of
late '90s, early 2000
New York alt-comedy scene.
-Yeah.
-And it was so hyperspecific,
and the first time we met,
I asked you, like, how --
based on your age,
I thought you must have been
so young when that was going on.
How did you know about it?
-Well, I started doing stand-up
pretty early.
I mean, the first time
I did my own stand-up,
I was like 14, maybe.
-Gotcha.
-Like, filling time
while they counted the votes
at a singing competition.
-Okay.
-And so I started in comedy
really early.
I always wanted to do this.
-How were you doing onstage
as a 14-year-old?
Were you doing okay with laughs?
-Weirdly, the first couple times
sometimes are amazing.
It's the next 90 times
that are train wrecks.
Like, I remember I was, like,
performing at
the Christian college
that my dad works at,
and my first time ever
doing my own comedy,
and I did this thing
where I was the Chuck E. Ch--
you know, the Chuck E. Cheese
robots?
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-I did this thing where I was,
like --
I was afraid to go to
Chuck E. Cheese as a kid
'cause I was afraid of
the characters.
They scared me.
So when the robots
would perform,
they say, "It's your birthday."
I heard a different song.
Then I'd play "Another Brick in
the Wall Part 2" by Pink Floyd.
[ Laughter ]
Then I'd do the --
And that's what I was doing
as a 14-year-old.
-That's very advanced
for a 14-year-old.
-Pretty advanced. Really weird.
-You were recognized for
your comedy very early.
You won a superlative
in high school.
You were the wittiest person.
I will say, when I first glanced
at this, I did read "whitest."
-Yeah, I could have qualified.
[ Laughter ]
-You could have won them both.
-I could have qualified.
You know, they really had to
mess with the aperture
on the camera to pick up
some of my skin tones.
-But this is good.
This means that
even as a young man,
your classmates, your peers
knew you to be comedy.
-Yes.
It was pretty clear what my
ambitions were to everyone else.
That was -- When the yearbook
committee came up to me
and they said,
"You got wittiest,"
I was like, "It does not get
better than this."
[ Laughter ]
"I am going to be the funniest
poetry professor
Middle Tennessee has ever seen."
[ Laughter ]
-What about your early
impressions as a kid?
Who were you doing then?
-Oh, my gosh.
I mean, Jar Jar Binks remains an
important inspiration to us all.
-Yeah.
-Especially me.
So I was doing a lot of
Jar Jar Binks.
My parents always had big groups
of friends over all the time.
They love entertaining,
and so they would drag me
out of my room and make me do
impressions for everybody.
And the big three were
Jar Jar Binks, Al Gore,
Louis Armstrong.
-Gotcha.
-And I took the trumpet out
for Louis Armstrong.
-You did?
You had your own trumpet?
-I would play a very bad bar of
"When the Saints
Go Marching In."
-And then did you start
doing open mikes?
-Yeah. So I went to
this Christian college,
where I had to sign a paper
saying that I won't sin ever.
-Okay.
-And so I was like, okay, good.
And that means you couldn't go
to bars
at the school that I went to.
And when I decided
that I needed to go full force
into stand-up professionally,
I Googled, like,
"stand-up open mike near me."
And it was always the most
just scum-of-the-Earth,
rat-den dive bars.
And I'm 19.
I go to the Christian college
down the road.
And I'm literally walking in
through patio doors
and getting a $5 Pepsi,
hoping not to get carded,
and then telling my jokes that
no one wanted to hear.
-Yeah.
-And I did that for
like three years before -- like
two years before I turned 21
and could legally be in there.
-Did the paper you signed ever
come back to haunt you?
Did they ever shake it
in your face?
-I think someone is hammering on
my dad's door right now,
now that I've made this
admission on national TV.
But you, sir, who is in charge
of the ethics
at the Christian college,
what are you doing up so late?
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
-Think about it.
Think about your choices.
-Think about your choices.
Well, I'm glad you made
the choices you did, James.
It's absolutely wonderful
having you on "SNL"
and it's wonderful having you
here tonight.
You guys, that's
James Austin Johnson.
"SNL," Saturday at 11:30 on NBC
and Peacock
with Willem Dafoe
and musical guest Katy Perry.